scp-682 versus scp-067  while this particular cross test was  never expected to destroy or even harm  the hard-to-destroy reptile researchers  figured that this all-telling fountain  pen might glean valuable information  about the monster  scp-067 is a pen that causes people to  compulsively write or draw about  themselves when the pen was given to  scp-682 it was horribly surprised when  it began drawing a complex image on the  floor when the image was done it threw  the pen across the room the resulting  picture was a self-portrait of scp-682  sitting atop a legion of dead roman  soldiers marked as the ninth legion  which had historically mysteriously  disappeared they may have been no closer  to defeating scp-682  but at least they solved that mystery